Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today. From my undergraduate alma mater, Dr.
Peg Riley, professor at UMass Amherst, who
runs an undergraduate research lab, focused
on the discovery and preclinical testing of
novel antimicrobials. Great to have you on.
I appreciate your time.
Speaker 3: My pleasure.
Speaker 1: So, OK, I mean, maybe just to get into
this and eventually we're going to kind of relate
this to the COVID virus and the suggestion
of things like ivermectin or azithromycin for
possible treatment or mitigation. When we think
about antibiotics to treat illness generally,
what are the sort of issues that we worry about
coming up, including antibiotic resistance at
a population level and other things?
Speaker 3: Sure. Well, as most of your
viewers will know, we use antibiotics in medicine
to either prevent or eliminate an infection by
bacteria. So they're very powerful. Fantastic.
They they developed the name Magic Bullet for good
reason. They'll wipe out a staph infection or what
have you rapidly. Now, when we first started using
those in the 1950s, we didn't understand that we
live with the microbiome, and that means we have
bacteria and other microbes in us, on us, around
us, and they're making us healthy by and large.
But antibiotics don't know the difference between
what's a healthy microbe in our microbiome and
what's the pathogen we want it to kill. So when
you take an antibiotic for a strep throat or an
ear infection or something much more serious, you
stand the chance of really wiping out a lot of
the good bacteria in your gut. The lactobacilli,
the buffet of Baxter, all those things that you
hear about in kimchi and yogurt, while all
of those can be decimated as well. And so
when we take antibiotics, when we shouldn't, which
is actually quite often, we could potentially
make our health worse rather than better
Speaker 1: when we think about the long
term of antibiotic use. If I if my research
is correct, there's only a few types of
antibiotics. Even though there's many specific
ones, there's really only a few families is the
path forward that eventually some new type of
antibiotic medication will be will be necessary?
Speaker 3: Well, I sure hope so, David, or
we're not going to survive long are now in
what we call the post antibiotic era. And that was
designated by the World Health Organization about
seven years ago now, where we have used, abused
and overused antibiotics to the point where we
have pathogens that that can cause fatal disease
in humans that no longer respond to antibiotics.
And I'll throw in one other sideline here, which
we often don't think about. In point of fact, 80
percent of our antibiotics are not used for human
health. They're used by the agricultural systems
to either produce fatter, healthier pigs
or to keep blade off of apples or tomatoes.
And so we're basically using these critical
drugs designed for humans originally
to make food cheaper. And that's something
that society has to talk about and decide if
that's a good route to be taking.
Speaker 1: When we talk about the
types of antimicrobials that you
work on and and look at developing
what's different about those versus antibiotics?
Speaker 3: Great question. So with an antibiotic,
it is designed. It is chosen by a pharmaceutical
company because it kills as much as possible.
In other words, as many bacterial species as is
possible. And the reason is the cost of developing
and and getting through clinical trials and
antibiotic. It's it's several billion dollars. Now
picture that I have urinary tract infection and
I want to take a drug to treat it. That's almost
always called bite caused by E. coli, which is
a species of bacteria in your gut. And my gut
normally doesn't bother us. In fact, we're happy
to have it for lots of reasons. But when it gets
into our urinary tract system, it causes problems
for some people. So imagine that I could give
you a pill that didn't kill everything in your
microbiome but just killed E.coli. Now, picture
that world. Now my microbiome is happy. I've
killed the E. coli and the selection for what you
mentioned earlier, antibiotic resistance is much
lower. So when I take a conventional antibiotic,
any bacterium in my body that can have a mutation
that will cause it to be able to resist that drug,
to fight it off will be selected for and
will increase in frequency in my body.
And that's what's happened over the last
50 years. That's why we have multidrug or
totally drug resistant pathogens to deal with.
Speaker 1: So let's maybe now introduce the
topic of COVID 19. We've seen the suggestions
and some of these things have been studied
that azithromycin known as Zithromax or a Z pack,
even though it's an antibiotic and COVID 19,
is a virus that in some situations
it can have an antiviral property,
and maybe it should be used for treating COVID
19. The placebo controlled studies I've seen don't
seem to show that it actually does work and in
that way, but it is something that's being studied
anti-parasitic ivermectin, hydroxychloroquine, et
cetera. What are their properties to some of these
that could work, at least theoretically
when you're dealing with a virus?
Speaker 3: Well, what they might do is impact
something in your body that then helps you
weather COVID better. Hmm. Does that make sense?
Yeah. Because these drugs are not designed to kill
a virus, it's in fact very challenging for us to
come up with medications that will kill viruses.
And that's why we don't have a lot of
them. It's not that we haven't tried.
Heaven forbid, we've actually tried very
hard now. A a drug to kill a protest,
a drug to to kill a bacterium could impact you
because maybe you have an underlying condition
that is caused by a bacterium or protest and that
when you get COVID, it exasperates either the
Corbet or exasperates the underlying condition.
And so possibly that's why some people report
feeling better when they take ivermectin, for
example. Now, personally, I'm a scientist. I
believe in data and until the FDA tells me
or shows me better yet, the clinical trials,
that means double blind, placebo based trials.
And for those who don't know what that means,
that means that Doc, who's administering the
trial, has no idea which patient got which.
They cannot bias their interpretation
of a patient's state status of health
because they don't know who got the
sugar pill. And that's the gold standard,
and that's why it takes so long to get drugs
approved by FDA. Those are tough studies
to carry out, especially during a pandemic,
Speaker 1: when when we think about the way
in which sometimes one medication or a few over
time, like at one point it was hydroxychloroquine,
azithromycin plus zinc with or without zinc,
ivermectin, et cetera. When we think about these
things entering the kind of media discussion and
becoming popularized sometimes on one political
side or sometimes more broadly, what do you
think underlies this? Is it that when there's
cheap, widely available medications around
and no clear treatment, doctors say,
let's just try, let's throw something at
it and just kind of see what happens is
that the genesis of a lot of these things?
Speaker 3: You know, I've never spoken to a
medical doctor who would have used any of those.
Oh, so I can't respond directly. What I can tell
you is if we compare this to vaccine hesitancy
example and I teach classes of 400 undergraduates,
none of whom are science majors, and
many of them start out in my class
agreeing that they are hesitant about
getting vaccinated and it came from
their parents or from their neighborhood or
what have you. And it's really an anxiety
because you don't understand the science, and we
scientists haven't taken the time to find ways to
help you understand the science. So I blame
the scientists, not the anti-vaxxers. Well,
do you think you better?
Speaker 1:
What tends to work in the classes
at changing the perspective on vaccination?
Speaker 3: I show them the history of the success
of vaccines. I show them how a clinical trial
is designed, how it's interpreted. What are the
issues that one has to confront when interpreting
the data? So without diving into the details,
I give them the sense of how rigorous science,
particularly science that is being used to
impact human health is is carried out under and
the incredible role the FDA plays in being the
gatekeeper. Because there are a lot of scientists
that are so excited about their ideas, I mean,
my drugs, I would love to give them to my
neighbors right now. I would love to, but
none of them are FDA approved, so I can't write.
And you can't help but be excited about your,
your drug or your idea. And that could be
tempting in a time where there's a pandemic where
individuals are dying. If there's something, why
not try it? That's the sort of attitude. Maybe
that accounts for why medical professionals
would do this, but I urge them to stop
Speaker 1: when it comes to the big picture impact
of this period of time, during which people are
maybe washing their hands more frequently, wearing
masks, not being around people as much. One fear
that some have expressed is this may attenuate the
strength of one's immune system merely by stopping
a lot of these little interactions
with different sorts of pathogens that
you interact with all the time and you sort of
build build resistance to so that you may come
out of the pandemic not having gotten COVID,
but may be generally less protected from an
immune immunity standpoint against things we
encounter on a regular basis. Is there something
to that? How long would one have to be, you know,
isolated from pathogens? And the other question
is if you're still eating food from grocery stores
and going to the gas station occasionally, are you
even really fully isolated from pathogens anyway?
Speaker 3: Thank you. That's a great question and
a great point you made at the end. So first
of all, one of the greatest impacts on this
new approach to life wherein in masking,
isolation, separation six feet or more
is going to be found in the nursing homes and
it already is being found in the nursing homes.
Their microbiomes are far less diverse on
average than an individual who may be just
isolated in their home with family members. So we
know that and less diverse microbiomes in general
are not as what we would call healthy. They're not
as able to stimulate our immune system just as you
were talking about a moment ago. But we don't live
in vacuums and we don't live in sterile chambers.
And so going for a walk, getting a little dirt on
your hands, believe it or not, eating the kinds
of foods you were talking about apples and high
fiber fiber rich diets are going to stimulate
the good microbes that are already possibly
present in your gut and and get you back into
the realm you want to be. So certainly, eating
fermented foods is always a good idea that helps
get the microbes enriched in your body that are so
protective like lactobacilli or Bifidobacterium.
Speaker 1: So for the average
person who had a year and a half of
less socializing and wearing a mask when out,
for example, is that really going to impact
their immune system in a significant way?
Speaker 3: I don't have the data to answer
that question, but I can tell you
from a sort of practical perspective,
good as masks are, that does not keep any of us
from using our hands to touch things right and
keep any of us from walking inside and touching
our face or our arm or what have you. So again,
we're not living in a sterile environment. We're
limiting the spread of things that carry easily in
the air. That's what we're doing. And that's why I
flew essentially evaporated last year, right? And
in fact, I went back and watched an old lecture
that I gave to my kids in this big class of nine
scientists. And I remember right at the beginning
of the COVID pandemic before it was a pandemic,
they were still in the class with me, 400 of
them in an auditorium. And I said, You know,
guys, I'm going to let you go today because we're
getting signs that this is highly infectious,
but there's good news on the horizon. I said, you
won't get flu this year, right? I laughed as they
were happy to leave the lecture room.
Speaker 1: And it turned out to be
quite quite accurate, in fact.
Speaker 3: Oh yes. I mean, it was
easy to predict. I mean, you wear
masks. You don't touch each other.
Gee, I wonder what'll happen with flu?
Speaker 1: Right, right. Yeah,
that'll be interesting to see this this flu
season, that is that's coming right now.
Dr. Pat Riley, Professor at UMass Amherst. Really
appreciate your time and your insights today.
Speaker 3: Thank you very much
for inviting me to join you.